Let's look at a famous NP-complete problem that we didn't cover in the unit,
called Hamiltonian paths.
Now a Hamiltonian path involves visiting every vertex of a graph exactly once,
and here's an example.
Let's say we have the very simple graph shown right here.
Well, in that case, a Hamiltonian path, if we start it here--let's say we'll
go to this vertex, then this vertex, then that vertex.
And that is a Hamiltonian path.
We visited each vertex exactly once.
Now there is another NP-complete problem called a Hamiltonian cycle
which is the same thing, but you have to start and end on the same vertex.
And that's actually impossible on this graph.
We can kind of start off here, but then, once we get here, there's no way
to get back to our starting vertex.
So now let's take a look at a slightly more complicated example.
And what I'd like to know is whether this graph has a Hamiltonian path
and, similarly, whether it has a Hamiltonian cycle.
Please check the corresponding box if it has either a Hamiltonian path,
a Hamiltonian cycle, or both.